bonjour françois bayrou bonjour voilà
trois semaines qu emmanuel macron a été
réélu toujours rien pas de nouveau
premier ministre pas de gouvernement
pourquoi c'est si long
d'abord ça va venir je pense qu'à un
moment et je pense que que la semaine
qui s'ouvre sera de ce point de vue là
révélatrice moi je ne suis pas choqué
que dans la transition entre deux
législatures deux périodes le président
de la république réélu prennent du temps
un peu de temps pour remettre les choses
à plat pour que on aperçoivent bien les
problèmes qui vont se poser et pour
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent il
n'ya toutes les autres démocraties dans
le monde je crois presque tout en tout
cas c'est vrai des plus grandes
démocraties américaine par exemple
lorsqu il y à une élection prennent deux
mois à peu près pour poser les choses
c'est différent aux états unis parce que
toute l'administration fait ses cartons
ce n'est pas seulement le sujet le sujet
c'est que le président élu a besoin
d'apercevoir la période qui s'ouvre
comme une période nouvelle et dans cette
période là qu'il au fond qu'il met en
place ses nouvelles équipes sauf que là
ça donne un sentiment de flottement dans
un sentiment d'improvisation au sommet
de l'état c'est pas problématique ça bon
d'abord c'est un sentiment mais je crois
pas du tout à ça je pense que à la fois
des équipes sont en place y compris les
équipes du gouvernement actuel mais vous
voyez bien les gouvernements justement
les mines et du gouvernement actuel le
premier ministre en tête qui
s'impatientent ils attendent en fait ils
attendent de pouvoir partir et compagnie
ils vont pas attendre longtemps non mais
vous voyez cette idée selon laquelle
faut être sous la pression des
événements sous la pression du
calendrier sous votre pression la
pression des médias en disant mais alors
ça tarde
je pense que c'est une idée qui ne
correspond pas à la difficulté d'avoir
peut-être mais à la difficulté des temps
que nous vivons je sais pas si on se
rend compte de ce qu'on de la période
dans laquelle on est entré on en dira
peut-être un mot mais c'est une période
si lourde de crise et de crise que pour
l'instant on n'aperçoit pas on en en
tête que le coc vide et que l'ukraine
mais il ya d'autres crises extrêmement
lourde qui sont en train de se présenter
1 devant nous à l'horizon est au fond le
fait que le président de la république
prenne un peu de temps pour poser les
choses moi ne me choque pas vous savez
bien que
ma position sur le fond mais c'était ma
position et elle n'a pas été retenues
s'étaient qu' on aurait très bien pu
aller jusqu'aux élections législatives
avec le gouvernement castex pour assumer
et assurer la transition et nommé un
nouveau gouvernement avec la nouvelle
majorité et donc ça ne s'est pas la
solution qui a été retenue mais c'est
une explication pourquoi ça me choque
moins que vous est-ce que ça doit être
une femme
ça va sinon femme apparemment ça va être
une femme mais bon vous savez bien vous
l'avait annoncé sur surtout l'étonnant
n'a rien n'assure du tout en écrasant
honnêtement françois bayrou 13 journées
comme vous on achète tout cas tous les
lloris et une femme tous les articles de
presse annoncé ce choix savez comme nous
que la presse parfois se trompent ça
c'est possible c'est peut-être ça vous
arrive ça toutefois la presse pas à vous
jamais mais après ce plus souvent aucun
priori c'est le choix des menus de mac
ronde se portaient sur une femme a
priori mais c'est ce qui vous est
jusqu'à n'apparaît pas sur la presse
juste avant un direct jusqu'à la
dernière minute
le président de la république en
fonction des éléments que j'indiquais
est libre de son choix et c'est très
bien comme ça parce que ce qui ce qui
n'est pas bien c'est ce qui ne serait
pas bien c'est cédé à une pression
quelle qu'elle soit médiatique ou
politique je pense que c'est très bien
qu'il soit libre de son choix qu'il
exerce en conscience
et qu'on essaie de faire connaissent et
de partager avec le pays avec nos
concitoyens avec l'opinion publique avec
ceux qui nous écoutent la gravité de ce
choix est ce que ça pourrait être quel
que soit son sexe une personne de gauche
macron a été élu et c'est l'engagement
de ma vie pour qu'on arrête de présenter
la politique française mais les jambes
en affichant politique vierge toute
éthique qui viennent ceux qui ont
rejoint emmanuel macron il ya cinq ans
mais ils viennent de la droite où ils
viennent de la gauche où ils viennent de
chez vous du centre où ils viennent du
centre droit et donc non jeu mais j'ai
été
le créateur d'un mouvement politique qui
précisément c'est défini en refusant de
se rallier à cette opposition que j'ai
toujours considéré comme simply c'est
stupide entre droite et gauche comme
signe avec ça dans la vie or c'est pas
ça ça n'est plus à le cadre emmanuel
macron a été élu pour dépasser ce cadre
vous comprendrez donc que c'est la
question qui là ne correspond pas y'a
pas de cursus élimine éliminatoires une
personnalité de gauche comme de droite
peut être nommé à matignon aujourd'hui
ou demain
personnalités qui fut de gauche et qui
fut de droite qui gardent des valeurs
d'engagement mais qui n'est pas d'un
camp le le propre arrêtons peut-être un
quart de seconde le propre de ceux de la
période dans laquelle nous sommes entrés
pas aujourd'hui mais en 2017 par
l'élection du président de la république
le propre de cette période c'est que
presque précisément on refuse de couper
en deux la vie politique parce que ça ne
correspond plus à la réalité regardez
les deux grands partis de gouvernement
de lundi de gauche le parti socialiste
l'autre dit de droite lr regardez dans
quel état l'élection présidentielle les
a laissés et vous comprendrez que les
citoyens eux ne veulent pas résumer les
choses à sa seule reste quelque chose à
des équipes des projets et j'aime pas le
mot mais tout le monde comprend ce qui
veut dire et des valeurs plus profonde
et ses serveurs profonde qui doivent
orienter les choix le nom qui circule le
plus en ce moment en parlant du poste de
premier ministre c'est celui d'une femme
venue de la droite catherine vautrin
catherine vautrin qui a donc été contre
le mariage pour tous qui a manifesté aux
côtés de la manif pour tous est ce que
c'est un handicap
je ne je ne participe pas
au concours de commentaires sur ce genre
de sujet président de la république qui
doit voir ça ma conviction à moi vous la
connaissez bien c'est qu'il faut qu'il y
ait il faudrait qu'il y ait à matignon
dans les choix que le président va faire
quelqu'un qui soit d'une très grande
proximité
philosophiques et politiques avec lui
l'unité de l'exécutif donc ça colle pas
le président premier ministre cette
unité là elle est essentielle à sur un
sujet du mariage ggv crée des liens
diffuse des images 1 comme vous
le le malaise si profond qui a duré
pendant des années entre un président de
la république de premier plan et un
premier ministe de premier plan mais ils
s'entendaient pas c'était mitterrand et
rocard et ça a provoqué quelque chose de
très de très déstabilisateur dans le
pays dans que moi je
je je me fie à cette grande proximité
qui doit exister françois bayrou haut
commissaire au plan maire de pau et
président du modem est l'invité de
france info le fil info à 8h40 et on se
retrouve dans un instant françois bayrou
voici thomas benech
finlande et suède prenne une mesure de
défense dans un environnement
stratégique modifié expliqué sur france
info le secrétaire général adjoint de
l'otan la finlande et suède veulent
adhérer à l'alliance atlantique dans le
sillage de l'invasion de l'ukraine à
part la russie le 24 février dernier
c'est officiel pour la finlande cette
adhésion à l'otan en suède feu vert hier
du parti social-démocrate au pouvoir la
ville de rennes l'a déjà fait grenoble
va t'elle autorisé à son tour le port du
burkini dans ces piscines municipales ce
maillot de bain couvrant la fois la tête
et le corps des femmes le conseil
municipal se prononce cet après midi en
cas de vote favorable la préfecture de
l'isère annonce d'ores et déjà qu'elle
demandera l'annulation de cette
délibération
le retrait du mali du g5 sahel et de sa
force anti djihadistes la junte malienne
au pouvoir accuse l'organisation de la
région d'être instrumentalisés elle
explique aussi vouloir dénoncer le refus
de confier au mali la présidence de ce
g5 restera-t-il ou pas au psg qu'il y
avait ma p a quasiment pris sa décision
le joueur du psg le confie hier soir
lors de la cérémonie des trophées unfpa
où il a été désigné meilleur joueur de
la saison chez les femmes la meilleure
joueuse c'est marie antoinette katoto
elle aussi joueuse du paris saint
germain
france info
le 8 30 france info sabia bras puis à
max chauvet ne jurait que le haut
commissaire au plan françois bayrou est
ce que vous avez envie de revenir au
gouvernement
a priori non il vous l'a pas proposé
manuel macron
si vous voulez bien connais un pacte
entre nous oui je suis amnésique dès
qu'il s'agit des conversations que je
peux m'imposer
ne venez pas remuer le couteau
souffrir ça se refuse le président de la
république qui vous demande intérieure
d'intégrer le gouvernement
c'est pas ça n'est pas le
ce n'est pas le moment de ma vie où je
suis des postes ministériels j'en ai
occupé longtemps
et je me sens plus heureux et plus
utiles dans les fonctions qui sont les
miennes aujourd'hui parce que
la mairie d'une ville aussi attachante
et fascinante que les la ville de pau et
tout son agglomération et tout le pays
de berne autour d'elle pour moi c'est
très important est peut-être en étant
enraciné comme ça je peux rendre je peux
rendre des services après le président
de la république naturellement à de l'
influence sur des décisions comme ça ce
week end jean luc mélenchon qui demande
aux français de les lire à matignon lors
des législatives du mois prochain à
amender son projet sur la question du
smic il est aujourd'hui ce smic à 1300
euros net par mois jean-luc mélenchon
proposait pendant la campagne
présidentielle de le porter almic 1400
désormais ses 1500 est ce qu'il faut
faire un geste aujourd'hui sur cette
question du smic d'abord on se demande
pourquoi on s'arrête à 1500 2 6 et 6 et
la surenchère chaque jour tout le monde
sourit en entendant ça je lui prédis ce
qui a changé depuis la campagne
présidentielle c'est qu'il ya une rêver
une réévaluation du montant de
l'inflation justement mais mais c'est
mais la question ce n'est pas celle là c
est ce que une augmentation brutale du
smic est bonne pour l'emploi
est ce que c est ce que c'est un signal
que les entreprises vont suivre pour
s'installer créer de l'emploi en france
et faire reculer ce avec quoi nous avons
vécu pendant des décennies qui est le
chômage est ce que c'est le bon signal
je pense que les réévaluations de
salaires doivent se faire à l'intérieur
de chaque branche a automatiquement à
l'intérieur de chaque par exemple c'est
l'autre débat en ce moment faut-il rien
et vous savez bien il ya un mécanisme
automatique sur l'inflation il ya un
mécanisme automatique comme vous savons
le smic oui pour le smic est donc donc
vous voyez bien que l'objection n'existe
pas vraiment mais c'est ça c'est la
question
l'élection enfin le
l'annnonce de l'union de la entre
guillemets gauche autour de mélenchon
d'abord pour beaucoup de français c'est
quelque chose de
d'extraordinairement
j'allais dire désespérant c'est pas si
vous avez vu les images le parti
socialiste qui a été le le très grand
parti de la social démocratie en france
et en europe alan jallet vire en chemise
et la corde au cou ce n'est à la grille
devant toutes vos caméras braquées sonné
à la grille de l efi pour aller se se
rendre
à cette pression pour garder quelques
dizaines de circonscriptions
abandonner tout ce qu'ils ont cru et le
programme de jean luc mélenchon on va le
découvrir
c'est un programme pour moi qui en ait
qui entraînerait la france dans un
gouffre
sortir de l'union européenne parce que
c'est bien ça que ça veut dire des
résistances assaillantes et désobéir au
traité ça veut dire que on sort de
l'union européenne j'ai déjà cité deux
exemples l'union européenne a interdit
les produits phytosanitaires dangereux
qu'est ce qui se passe si l'espagne
demain 10 grands pays de maraîchage et
de production de de fruits et de légumes
si l'espagne dit écoutez moi je ne
respecterais pas je sortirai c'est un
traité qui ne me va pas je désobéis ray
l'europe explose
qu'est ce qui se passe si l'ensemble des
pays européens ayant pris une décision
historique qui est d'instaurer une
fiscalité minimale sur toutes les
entreprises y compris les grandes
multinationales
fiscalité minimale de 15 pour cent ce
qui n'est pas rien qu'est ce qui se
passe si en somalie déjà sur plusieurs
traités plusieurs pays désobéissent jeu
n'ont pas si le principe de l'europe
comme le principe de toute association
c'est que quand on prend une décision
ensemble on la respecte les six ans a
désobéi pendant ces cibles non l'a pas
désobéi on a assez joyeusement elle a
pris en accord avec l'ensemble des pays
européens
des décisions qui étaient des décisions
de sauvegarde et c'est très bien je si
le luxembourg ou s'il a les pays bas 10
nous aussi l'irlande contre qui cette
décision a été prise et nous désirons
retraités qu'est ce qui reste de l'union
européenne donc sortir de l'union
européenne avec des des gestes
symboliques qui sont qu'on n'a pas vu
mais qui sont incroyablement révélateur
par exemple il y a dans le programme de
mélenchon le fait qu'on retirera les
drapeaux européens de tous les bâtiments
publics français
est ce que est ce que vous voyez à quel
point cette décision là est une décision
symbolique annoncé une décision
symbolique
tellement choquant mais ya pas que ça
il dit que l'urgence est de sortir de
l'otan vous avez un choc historique
séculaire avec poutine qui a attaqué
l'ukraine
avec l'armée russe qui se trouve
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté
poutine lui-même qui devant son peuple
sait très bien que il ya des mouvements
profonds qu'ils disent mais c'est pas
notre guerre qu'est ce qu'on fait ce
sont nos frères nos cousins nos voisins
on a toujours commercer ans est toujours
mariée avec eux
et si c'est la france la france avec son
histoire qui dit eh bien nous allons
nous retirer de l'alliance atlantique au
moment où la suède et la finlande qui
ont une tradition de neutralité
and annoncé qu'ils allaient y adhérer
mais quel coup de poignard plus
spectaculaires dans le dos peut-on
donner
qu elle quel coup de poignard
étrangères jean luc mélenchon dit bien
qu'il fera sera en accord avec emmanuel
macron tu auras pas une et plus dur mais
c'est entre les deux c'est ce qu'il dit
arrêtons arrêtons d'entrer dans les
éléments de langage des gens qui dansent
vous disent qu'ils aiment c'est parce
qu'il dit tous ses programmes toutes ces
annonces toutes ces déclarations et vous
pouvez les retrouver sans aucune
difficulté 10 ce que je dis moi et puis
annoncé
qu'il n'y aura plus de financements
publics pour les écoles privées dès
l'instant que ces écoles privées
n'entrerait pas dans le cadre général
c'est-à-dire l'affectation des élèves
mais est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'on va
ainsi relancer des querelles des guerres
qui sont celles de la qui sont celles de
la société française depuis longtemps et
puis l'idée vous parliez du bikini
annoncer qu'on va supprimer la loi
contre le séparatisme annoncer qu'on va
supprimer les bacs les identités
n'étaient ce que je vous propose est
monté de police qui met deux qui
essaient de maintenir de l'ordre dans
les situations les plus difficiles et on
sait ce que c'est quand on est maire est
ce que est ce que ces randos service à
la stabilité de la france et donc au
bout du compte à son image et donc au
bout du compte à son économie et à
l'installation que nous avons vécu
depuis des années d'entreprise pour
créer de l'emploi et des salaires on a
compris que vous ne voterez part pour la
nuque aux législatives je veux bien
réveillé vous avez le toute petite pause
le temps du fil info à 8h50 avec thomas
des ménages on poursuit dans un instant
avec vous françois bayrou
après plus de deux ans à le porter fini
le masque dans les transports en commun
à partir d'aujourd'hui dans les bus les
métros et les trains il n'est plus
obligatoire de vous couvrir à la bouche
un cyclone et le masque encore
nécessaires en revanche lorsque vous
allez à la pharmacie dans les ehpad
ainsi qu'à l'hôpital le chef de l'état
fait durer le suspense toujours pas de
nouveau premier ministre désigné ça va
venir la semaine qui s'ouvre sera
révélatrice indique sur france info
françois bayrou haut commissaire au plan
invité de 8,30 france info la préfecture
de l'isère très bien si la ville de
grenoble autorisent aujourd'hui le port
du burkini dans ces piscines alors elle
saisira le tribunal administratif le
burqini ce maillot couvrant à la fois la
tête et le corps des femmes déjà
autorisé dans les piscines de la ville
de rennes bataille judiciaire autour des
nouvelles aventures de gaston lagaffe
les éditions dupuis promettait en mars
dernier un nouvel album la fille de
franquin le créateur de ce personnage de
bande dessinée s'y opposent audience
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal de
bruxelles
franceinfo
le 8 30 france info salia bras kia marc
fauvelle toujours avec françois bayrou
on parlait il ya quelques instants
rapidement du burkini que le maire
écologiste de grenoble si vous me
permettez juste sur le programme de
mélenchon oui il ya une chose
maintenant on va regarder les programmes
avant on regarde et on le connaissait
pendant la présidentielle création non à
l'état du tout c'est ça n'a pas été
regardé parce que s'étaient focalisés
sur le programme de l'extrême droite
mais maintenant on pourra vendre et
celui-ci l'a soumis régulièrement on
parle du programme et allez-y maintenant
il ya des choses qu'on n'a pas vu par
exemple jean luc mélenchon annonce qu'il
va supprimer frontex vous savez cette
sept gardes aux frontières de l'union
européenne pour empêcher qu'il y ait des
mouvements de population absolument
incontrôlée et déstabilisant et même il
annonce que pour les mineurs qui sont
sur le territoire français on aura plus
de tests pour savoir quel est leur âge
réel est ce que tout ça ce n'est pas d
élément de déstabilisation annoncé
grave pour ce que sera l'equilibre
futurs de la société française est
simplement sous le sous le
le
les manifestations verbales les plus
dynamiques plus dynamique derrière se
cache un programme ce programme là est
un programme dangereux et je suis
absolument persuadé que ce doit être une
des responsabilités de l'élection
législative que de le révéler le burqini
françois bayrou le maire de grenoble
écologistes et rituels souhaite donc
l'autorisé dans ces piscines au non dit
il de la liberté est ce que vous
pourriez faire la même chose chez vous à
pau non parce que ça ne serait pas c'est
une décision qui est un signal c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que vous voyez à
prêter c'est un signal pour dire que les
mouvements
islamistes la tentative d'imposer une
vision
militante de la religion dans la société
française va au fond être considéré
comme anodines et qu'on va l'accepter
lui dit je vais autoriser les burqini
mais aussi autoriser les femmes qui
veulent se baigner seins nus écoutez si
ça vous convainc
tant que citoyenne si ça vous convient
c'est votre responsabilité
la mienne est de dire cela ne peut être
interprété que comme un signal
d'encouragement
à un islam knees moi en tout cas une une
volonté religieuse militante il a hérité
il faut laisser chaque vous le chaque
ville décide et rennes par exemple
l'autorisent déjà depuis plusieurs
années vous souhaitez que chaque maire
puisse faire assister au sur cette
question où est ce qu'il faut un cadre
c'est sa responsabilité et le bon sens
élémentaire consiste à voir non pas les
décisions mais le signal que les
décisions envoient vous savez il ya ce
vieux proverbe chinois qui dit quand le
sage montre la lune l'imbécile regarde
le doigt la décision le la décision
prise c'est évidemment un signal et
c'est ce signal dont il faut comprendre
le sens et qu'il faut à mon sens éviter
le vote aura lieu aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
parlé des législatives vous avez donc tu
as fait fortement sur le programme des
insoumis de la nuque comme on dit
l'union de gauche vous aussi au niveau
de la majorité où vous êtes alliés entre
partis de la majorité on a beaucoup
parlé du côté des insoumis de la
candidature de taabo afce des insoumis
parce qu'il est accusé de violences
sexuelles par plusieurs femmes et donc
il a été d investi par les insoumis il y
ait une autre affaire de votre côté il
s'agit d'un député qui est donc lui-même
réinvesti par la majorité présidentielle
et à la différence près c'est que lui il
a été condamné pour violence conjugale
je précise salia qu'on ne donnera pas
son nom ici ni sa circonscription
mais qu' une histoire de temps de parole
ce avec l'art comme nous demande à
chaque fois qu'on accorde et vous allez
parler pendant je ne sais pas combien de
temps de se dé but est d'aller invité
tous les autres candidats ce qu'on ne
pourra pas faire sur ce plateau
l'ardente celle ci s'avère de qui vous
parlez
département qui s'appelle la dordogne un
député que vous avez investi qui a été
condamné pour violence conjugale
il ya des lois
je n'aime pas qu'on juge avant le
jugement il a été jugé condamné et il
n'a pas fait appel lorsqu'il ya jugement
il ya des sanctions qui s'appliquent
est ce que ces sanctions sont appliquées
dans le cas précis je ne connais pas le
dossier mais je suis pour que les
sanctions soient appliquées de manière
il a été condamné à une amende il a
décidé de ne pas faire appel du jugement
de première instance il a donc été
investi à la renaissance par la majorité
je regarderai non non vous pose la
question françois bayrou parce qu'on
peut pas être qu'on peut décréter c'est
ça ma question est ce qu'on peut
décréter l'égalité femmes hommes comme
grande cause du quinquennat et investir
cette personne là encore une fois je ne
connais pas le dossier je ne sais pas
mais vous avez participé je vais décider
de qui et de quoi vous parlez mais je
vous promets de regarder bien sûr
emmanuel macron a paraît-il en lisant la
pression soit bayrou pousser un coup de
gueule en voyant la photo de l'acte de
naissance de renaissance vous faites
partie de cet ensemble de d'ensemble
pardon il avait raison voilà quatre
hommes sur la photo qui avait un peu
l'air de s'ennuyer au moment où elle a
été prise pas une femme à l'horizon il a
eu raison de s'énerver il a eu raison de
s'énerver franchement la communication
ça fait partie de la politique qu'est ce
qui était raté sur cette photo où
rien n'allait à mes yeux rien n'allait
plus casting 80 cadre de la photo le
casting c'était fait pour qu'on se
succèdent au micro n'a été placé dans un
cadre qui était pas du tout le nôtre
avec une étiquette qui était pas du tout
la nôtre qui venait de la campagne
précédente et donc moi aussi je suis
tout à fait prêt à me joindre à la au
coup de gueule vous autres au coup de
gueule simplement nous sommes arrivés
dans une pièce et nous avons découvert
ils savent que la sauv ailleurs où vous
parlez d'image vous parlez de
communication dans le fond c'est pas
plus dérangeant qui est pas de femmes
dirigeantes
thiel donc c'est ça serait dérangeant et
comme vous savez j'ai constamment dans
ma vie donner des responsabilités aux
femmes et ça continue mais les quatre
partis aujourd'hui sont dirigés par des
hommes oui non ce n'est pas quatre
parties ces trois parties est bon les
trois partis avaient des hommes à leur
tête et naturellement le il faut
équilibrer de manière absolument
certaine et c'est ce que nous avons fait
je pense que nous avons
l'equilibre femmes hommes dans les
investitures de des élections
législatives le plus précis et le plus
parfait de tous les partis français si
j'ai bien lu le la presse j'ai pas fais
l'analyse de tous les partis français
bon ça mérite aussi qu'on le souligne et
s'il ya eu des erreurs de communication
mais bon
richard ferrand edouard philippe et moi
nous sommes ce que nous sommes
génétiquement et on va on va pas non
plus mais il aurait fallu évidemment que
nous rendions complètement équilibré
cette tribune c'était de ce point de vue
là le moins que l'on puisse se dire une
faute de communication merci beaucoup de
fautes de réalité peut-être même c'était
ni le cadre ni les inscriptions neil
allures de la photo tout ça était oui à
revoir très très très loin des standards
qu'on pourrait atteindre merci beaucoup
françois bayrou très bonne journée à
vous